hello everyone and welcome back to game
16 of the 1972 World Chess Championship
match between Robert James Fischer and
Boris the city of its passkey
the result is 9 to 6 in Fischer's favor
and by this point in the match a lot of
players a lot of people in Spassky scamp
and everyone in the Soviet Union were
wondering if there was something else
perhaps affecting his past his play
maybe it was as they said it was a
hypnosis or maybe they were affecting
Spassky in some other fashion Nikolay
Crowe gives back the second that said
that this was a science of nonsense and
there was no merit to do it a finger
agreed with him everyone in the camp
agreed with him but as this situation
and the match kept getting worse and
worse for Spassky he had this he had a
lot of chances but he he simply didn't
use them if you've been following the
match so far you you you could have seen
that Spassky created amazing chances
throughout the match so far in the first
15 games but that he just didn't go
through and won the games that he should
have won and now there were a couple of
famous psychiatrist
psychiatrist visiting and they said that
Spassky should even though Fischer's
protests were directed towards the chief
arbiter the organizers and such they are
most mostly they're affecting Spassky
and that Spassky shirt should either
disregard them completely and not even
listen to them or fighting them actively
perhaps he should protest himself to
fight you know fire wood fire but one
such a famous Soviet psychiatrist mr.
hartounian
visited Reykjavik and he said in his own
words that Fischer has a strong
personality of a psychopathic
disposition and his behavior affects
Spassky but it is definitely not
hypnosis or anything and that then later
on when situation really became as it is
now 9:00 to 6:00 and it's already game
16 the Soviets thought that perhaps
Fischer was using some sort of machines
or electronic device devices to affect
Spassky is a thinking process and they
filed an official appeal to the chief
arbiter a lot of Schmidt and the niccola
Corgi said that he was a very important
pressed but he was amazed that effing
Geller would actually do this because so
far Geller dismissed all of these claims
that there was anything going on and
rumors were that they were doing it
proactively so if Spassky loses the
match and then the consequences from the
Soviet Union would be less severe if
perhaps you know if Spassky perhaps lost
the match due to him being influenced by
Fischer in some way then maybe maybe the
consequences will not be so severe
weather this is only a rumor of not it's
hard to say but it is well known what
happens to Soviet players when they lose
against the Western players so I think
our filed an official protest the chief
arbitral author Schmidt and they stopped
the match briefly to inspect the playing
hall they inspected everything from the
lights as special lights were installed
the one Fischer wanted they especially
inspected Fischer's charest the Fischer
had a custom-made chair and it was a
really an impressive chair you might
remember that Spassky also had a
custom-made shirt for him because he
wanted one that swivels like Fischer's
and then while they were inspecting the
chair they x-rayed Fischer's chair and
they found a small metallic object in it
and everyone was really anxious about
what it was and they immediately took
the chair apart and what they found
inside the chair was a very small
screwdriver that the workers that were
assembling the chair left inside so
there was really nothing to it and when
they finished inspecting everything to
hold the chairs the the lights
everything they just found nothing and
they were really unimpressed with
themselves and crow Bo said that they
really they really didn't need to do
this and also and the reporters the
reporters had a very nice joke they said
that Fischer finally has a date but it
was the woman and they saw a Fisher
which was actually a judge from from New
York from New York Supreme Court she
came to Reykjavik
to inform Fisher that his accounts force
were frozen and that his money that he
made from the two books that he authored
that he will not be able to use it until
he figures out to what
what's going on with Chester Fox and
this whole idea about a lawsuit and the
Icelandic Chess Federation said that
they will in no way be supporting mr.
Chester Fox in his attempts to sue
Fischer in in Iceland so there we have
it a little you know intro into this
game and we have a game 16 Fisher again
has the white pieces and he opens with E
for he hasn't opened with e4 since game
10 Spassky replies with E 5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 once again
going for the rule opus a 6 and here
Fischer instead of Bishop to a4 like in
game 10 a Bishop captures on c6 Fischer
had a lot of success with this exchange
variation of the real opus in the past
so Spassky of course and his team
prepared a lot for it during the
training camp D captures and here we
have castles Glee which also mentions
that this gives a black much more
problems than the media the d4 because
now after castling as names which would
say the threat is much stronger than the
execution now black really has to worry
about this Knight captures on e5 idea
and he has to make something either
Bishop to d6 or f6 Spassky in this case
plays f6 and okay we have d4 and now
Bishop to g4 also capturing is a capture
Sun d4 but if you don't gain anything by
capturing no reason to capture D captors
on e5 Queen captures on d1 rook captures
and e1 and now F captures on e5 there is
a one game glitch mentions where he
played the first the Bishop captures to
ruin White's pawn structure here and
glitch won that game with black but
Fischer also played one game where he
had white in this position and Fischer
won that game so spacier made a very you
know calculated risk here F captures on
e5 and the engine definitely agrees with
Spassky rook to d3 a nice rook lift that
unpinned this Knight and also now rook
captures on f3 is possible if Spassky
decides to capture
the bone structure on the kingside will
be it will be intact and this is not a
new move Fischer already plated against
miss Levine Monte Carlo in 1967
so Spassky most likely knows this we
have Bishop to d6
and now comes the night to D - I would
have Knight to f6 Knight to c4 and then
out Knight captures on e4 Fischer plays
Knight see captures on e5 and now comes
Bishop captures on f3 Knight captures on
f3 castles and Bishop to e3 b5 and the
now comes c4 Fischer's idea is since he
has a pawn majority and the King said
it's three points against two points in
space he does have a majority on the
Queen side although his see pawns are
double he plays C 4 and now Spassky can
either capture and triple his pawns on
the Queen side which will definitely go
nicely with Fisher's rook as rooks rule
of the doubled and tripled pawns but his
main idea is to bring the other rook
over to c1 push c5 and block off the
Queen side completely so the Queen side
becomes blocked and he can control the
center with his bishop at night then
perhaps he can mobilize his pawns on the
Kings side where he has a pawn majority
so okay rook a to b 8s pass key is not
preparing the capture on c4 and open up
the V file rook to c1 fishery is
preparing to push c5 but Spassky doesn't
allow it
B captures on c4 and now comes rook to
d4 if you play something like rook
captures and c4 immediately you don't
you're not really attacking the knight
because after rook captures here you
can't capture it after room b1 check you
have to give up the piece just to
prevent checkmate a bit of the c1 and
after rook captures only now you can
defend it by 91 not rook e1 as this
would all be up to be 4 but but 91 and
now you're simply down upon still it's a
double C pawn but a much better position
for black so after Bishop B captors on
c4 rook to d4 now you you're definitely
attacking the knight now comes Rock F to
e8 defending the knight and now you're
keeping this Knight and a beautiful
efore central square and Fischer decides
the force some exchanges to get it away
from there Knight d2
forcing exchanges Knight capture
rook captures and now comes Luke to e4
Spassky finds a very nice move that will
defend his c4 pawn as his see pawns are
tripled now and this is a serious
handicap if you're not in time to defend
it but suppose we calculate properly
here we have g3 by Fischer seems like an
order move why not King to f1 getting
your King into the game immediately if
King to f1 then Fischer would as
possible indeed have Bishop captures on
h2 unlike Fischer's Fisher's captures
Bishop captures on h2 in game 1 because
here g3 doesn't do anything it doesn't
trap the bishop sorry about that
it doesn't trap the bishop because
bishop can capture on g3 pawn captures
and now hero bishop on e3 is unguarded
route captures and you just lost a lot
of points on the Kings side so after
rook to e4 first g3 now the king can
come into the game Bishop to e5 and now
rook to c2 Fischer stubbornly is
defending the b2 pawn and now comes team
to f7 Spassky is bringing his King into
the game and Fischer does the same rook
captures on beat 2 and now comes King to
f3 with an attack and spassky's broken
e4 a much better move than capturing on
me - because if captures then Spassky
has this very nice c3 move Ruby C - and
now captures here Bishop captures and
now rook comes to a4 and you can't
capture and c6 because of rook captures
on a2 and also the bishop on e5 is very
conveniently defending the c7 pawn so
after this rook to be - King to f3 like
we said Fischer doesn't have time for
the in-between rook to d7 check because
after King t6 his rook is under attack
and after rook captures it
sorry about it after rook captures
Bishop captures
now comes Road captors on c7 but now
King attacks rook and while you have to
waste time to deal with this for example
rook to f7 black will simply start
pushing his past pawn and the black will
win this game so like we said after rook
to be - King to f3 by Fischer the
strongest move c3 with this moves baski
forces a series of exchanges that will
really simplify the game as you'll see
King characters on e4 by Fischer seek a
person d2 rope cap
sandy - and now not capturing Gandhi -
as this overly simple simplifies the
game but rather rook to b5 preparing
rook to a5 and okay rook the c2 by
Fischer going after the doubled pawns
we have Bishop to see Bishop to d6 and
now rope captures on c6 and pass key
goes rook to a5 attacking the a to pawn
a bishop to f4 offering a trade of
bishops we have looked way for check
King back to f3 and now rook to a3 check
King to e4 back and now rook captures on
a2 or you can simply continue checking
but Spassky will try something else
rook captures on a2 we have Bishop
captures on d6 seek a person B 6 and now
Road captures on d6 and here it's pasta
plays rook captures on f2 you could also
try a 5 but it's no better after a 5
let's say rook to a6 you have to put a
rug behind the passed pawn a4 white will
push on the King side black will push on
the Queen side after you get to the King
behind your pawns for example g4 a 2 is
coming and now white can simply continue
checking the black King and even though
even if black somehow goes after the
white rook here doesn't really matter
you will never have a check to give with
the black rook and then after if you
have removed the rock white will be able
to gobble up this pawn and still you've
gained nothing so after rook the d6 rook
to f2 capturing a pawn we have rook
captures on a6 and now rook captures on
h2 and here
Spassky is up upon but this is a well
known theoretical draw if you have two
points on the King side against one pawn
on the King side and two rooks then it's
a draw two points mean nothing if there
are looks into the game if the pawns are
on the same side of the board so here a
freshman simply pay play the King to f3
he doesn't fall out rook to have to to
cut off the White King from the defense
of the pawn king to f3 and here
rook to d2 and here Spassky knows this
is a draw officials this is a draw
pretty much everyone knows this is a
draw but perhaps because Fischer made
Spassky come finish the adjourned game
in game 15 he had to come to play into
the playing call even though they only
played three moves
and the draw was offered by phone
perhaps this is why Spassky decided to
torture Fischer here even though there's
really no way for you to win this game
but as there's no way to lose this game
you know it really doesn't hurt to at
least try perhaps the other guy blunders
rope to a7 check we have king of sex
rock a6 checking his 7r okay seven track
king
rook to d7 of course you don't want to
trade rooks if you trade rocks them two
points are much better than one pawn
rook to a2 King e6 King G to rocky seven
King to h3 King to f6 we have rocky six
check roadblocks
again you have to decline the drug trade
Spassky pushes upon h6r okay to King f5
look to f2 check King to g5 and now rook
to f7 so all Fischer has to do is avoid
a rock trade and not fall into any any
checkmating ideas we have g6 rock back
to a for not allowing booking any moves
but the King doesn't really have all
that many squares h5 now comes rook to
f3 rook to have sex and ugly again
declining the rook trade rook to e6 rock
to f3 rook to e4 rook to a3 King to h6
rock to a sec spinning the pawn rook to
e5 King to h4 and now rook to e4 check
pressure goes back rock to e7 King to h4
rook to e5 cutting the King off and also
rook the b6 still pinning the the Jeep
on not allowing the pond to be pushed to
g5 King g7 route before king h6
rugby 6 Rocky one King to a ch3 group -
h1 check King G - ok one King h3 and
here after rook to a 4
this is finally move 60 the players
agree to a draw and here the result is
nine and a half to six and a half in
Fishers favour
so it's a the game could have ended 30
moves ago but for some reason as Pascal
II decided to torture Fischer and
perhaps it's a his way of using some
sort of psychological warfare against
Fischer to get even with Fischer for
using such such non chess thing
against him but yeah and an interesting
game but specifically showed him that
against him that he really has nothing
to look for in the exchange variation of
the real opus even though he had a lot
of success with it in the past so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank James Crenshaw a bit
matter Joseph Joseph odd or Joffrey
Cooke and Jimmy a bar band for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check too on my
previous video so you're thankful for
watching and I'll see you soon
most likely with game 17 of this epic
match thank you all and I'll see you
soon